le courageux peuple ukrainien se bat
pour lui-même et il se bat également
pour nous tous en ce moment le crâne se
positionne bravement comme le leader
moral du monde libre
comment y à le voir dans le reportage de
marie ève bédard il en faut beaucoup de
courage de résilience et le courage
justement des ukrainiens a été saluée
notamment par le gouvernement trudeau en
marge de la londe de nouvelles sanctions
contre la russie est depuis les derniers
jours de nombreux citoyens dits
ordinaires choisissent de prendre les
armes en ukraine pour défendre leur
ville face aux russes l'une d'entre
elles est lissière vassy lenco lé député
du parti au los au parlement de
l'ukraine et mère de trois jeunes
enfants son but va voir neuf mois de mai
alors je lui parlais tout à l'heure tout
près de kiev c'est là qu'on la rejoigne
et on écoute
bonsoir madame wasilenkoff merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans les
moments extrêmement dramatique pour vous
bonsoir je suis ravi d'être là avec vous
de pouvoir parler sur la situation dans
mon pays dans le grain oui il est
important aussi pour vous comme député
de donner l'exemple de prendre vous même
les armes on vous a vu
m'avait avec une arme à côté à vos côtés
c'est important pour vous d'être
solidaire aussi du peuple ukrainien qui
entend résister à l'invasion russe
tout à fait c'est le peuple ukrainien
qui est unie aujourd'hui contre le plus
grand agresseurs du monde la fédération
russe avec son président vladimir
poutine qui est devenu fou avec le
pouvoir et qui rêve de rétablir le grand
empire russe et pour ça il veut détruire
ukraine comme un pays indépendant
il veut et écraser le peuple ukrainien
quand même un peu plus libre avez vous
l'impression que la mobilisation
mondiale de l'union européenne des pays
de l'otan autour de l'aide militaire qui
est envoyée mais non pas de deux soldats
sur le terrain peut aider l'ukraine à
vaincre poutine
bien sûr que ça aide et ça doit à
continuer à venir mais de toute façon le
prince est un pays tout petit en
comparaison à la russie et notre armée à
1 est pas aussi grande que les millions
de soldats que poutine va déjà envoyé
dès demain en ukraine et c'est pour ça
que les députés ukrainiens font l'appel
à la communauté internationale deux
envoyés en ukraine
désarmé a envoyés en ukraine à des
avions qui peuvent fermer notre ciel et
qui peuvent protéger le peuple ukrainien
et surtout les femmes les enfants
de
bombardements qui vient de la russie et
des missiles qui sont envoyées déjà
maintenant non seulement de la russie
mais aussi de la belle rosie vous êtes
vous-même mère de famille avec trois
enfants je crois vous avez un tout petit
bébé de quelques mois est-ce que vous
vous sentez malgré tout à l'abri au
contraire vous êtes inquiète vous avez
peur de l'avenir
c'est vrai je suis mère de trois enfants
mme appli petit pas avoir neuf mois
demain est assez vrai que comme toutes
les mères ukrainienne j'ai trop peur
pour mes enfants pour leur futur pour ma
famille mais toujours je suis déterminé
à être là resté sur le terrain et
combattre cette agression qui qui est
escale et qui devient de plus en plus
grands chaque jour je suis confidente
je suis sûre que le peuple kenyan va
vaincre ce mal
ce mâle violent qui vient de la russie
on perçoit et c'est
votre prise gazoline ski comme un grand
leader qui assume très bien son rôle
qu'ils étaient pas préparés pour jouer
ce rôle-là de
l'affronter confronté à poutine on parle
de lui comme étant la cible numéro 1 de
poutine est ce que
parlez-nous de zelensky et de son
courage
c'est absolument vrai tout ce que vous
venez de dire ce qui a vraiment pu se
changer à un leader demande très fort en
leader militaire d'un pays qui
qui met la liberté comme une plus grande
valeur et alors il l'a acquis hier avec
avec son peuple avec ses armes et il est
prêt à être un exemple pourrait il aller
jusqu'au jusqu'au bout est ce que vous
croyez que poutine va mettre à exécution
son plan d'éliminer le président et
lenski il dit que c'est la cible numéro
1 que des mercenaires seraient déjà en
ukraine pour exécuter zelensky est ce
que est ce que vous avez peur de ça
poutine est
devenu absolument à
absolument obsédé par le pouvoir est
absolument obsédé par ce l'idée qu'il
doit vaincre le grain des peuples libres
craignant alors il ne va pas s'arrêter à
rien il va utiliser des manipulations il
va utiliser le terreur et il va
continuer à terroriser
les peuples civile disent maintenant
j'ai eu là un plan formation qu'il a
déjà arrêté à
83 objets civils
rajiv c'est une très grande ville à
l'est de l'ukraine avec plus de 2
millions habitants c'est la deuxième
plus grande ville en ukraine et alors là
les gens innocents les femmes les
enfants ils sont sujets à des missiles
qui sont envoyées dans leur quartier
résidentiel alors si on a à un homme
comme ça qui donne à des commandes assez
armé a pour
jeter des bombes et des missiles sur des
objets civils vous pouvez bien imaginer
que il peut faire du président ukrainien
une cible et bill mercenaires n'importe
quel prix pour qu'il la ccim or
plusieurs estime que poutine est
irrationnel déconnecté tout ça il
entreprend néanmoins des négociations
est ce que c'est un leurre pour vous ces
négociations diversion où il y a des
chances de de réussite
si j'ai bien compris de la question les
négociations ils se sont passées
aujourd'hui ni alors c'était juste le
premier le premier la première étape de
ces négociations on va en avoir plus
quand il y a les négociations c'est que
les diplomates et parle alors les armes
se font silence en ce moment là donc ça
nous donne un peu de temps pour
réagir et réhabilité dans nos forces
nous armer à pour qu'on puisse nous
défendre encore plus mais avec ces
négociations on voit déjà que les russes
étaient très à
très très mécontent du résultat le voir
dans les interviews il était vraiment
pas trop confident quand il parlait pas
trop sûrs d'eux quand il parlait aux
journalistes
mais les ukrainiens de l'autre côté il
était vraiment trop fort et à l'âge
comprendre de ces signes de 6,6 signa
plutôt psychologique en analysant la
situation que les russes ne sache pas
comment y revenir a dit m poutine leur
dire que les ukrainiens ne vont pas
céder et toujours continuer à se battre
comme contre cette agression et ce
régime empirique très bien les services
locaux
réputés ukrainienne mère de famille
résistante merci beaucoup de nous avoir
parlé ce soir courage courage et on se
reparle très bientôt bonne nuit
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit